so i i've got the uh the numbers pulled
up and nbc
just goes by the the key states that
matter and they say in arizona they have
until november 23rd to finalize their
local results
the secretary of state certifies
statewide results on the 30th in
pennsylvania they have until november
10th
for unofficial vote tallies to be
provided to the secretary of the
commonwealth
november 23rd is the last day for local
officials to submit certified election
results
if there's a difference of 0.5 or less
then they
uh the secretary must order a recount by
november 12th
if at least three voters in each county
allege errors or discrepancies in the
count
a recount could also be triggered any
recount must be completed by november
24th
and local election officials must submit
certified recount results
to the secretary by the 25th in michigan
november 17th
for their uh local election officials
must complete county by 17th
provide the results by the 23rd for for
certification
any petitions for recount must be
submitted by the 25th wisconsin they say
the 17th
and then you know there's some special
rules uh
13th for georgia followed by 20 the 20th
to certify
unofficial results in the 13th north
carolina okay
we go to december 8th last day for
states to resolve election disputes
states must certify election outcomes at
least six days before the electoral
college meets
known as the safe harbor deadline if
they want to avoid congress getting
involved in resolving potential disputes
that means any court challenges to state
election results must be settled by
december 8 2020
if states certify election outcomes by
this deadline congress must accept the
results as valid
december 14th electors cast their
ballots
they meet in their respective states to
cast their ballots for president and
vice president
on the second monday after the second
wednesday in december in every state
except nebraska and maine
electors vote on winner takes all basis
this we understand and then some are
split
december 23rd president of the senate
receives electoral vote certificates
by january 6 congress counts electoral
votes
and on january 20th they inaugurate the
new president so if
if there's a pending court case by
december 8th
uh and the the state is unable to
deliver votes
what's what happens then my
understanding is that
it's rejected there's there's no count
there's no votes
so the state is just gone whoa and so
this is what
and look i'm not i'm not a legal expert
i'm not constitutionalist i i don't know
that that's exactly true
um but you know it would have to be it i
don't know that it's even been litigated
before so we wouldn't
it's hard to have a firm answer one way
or another yeah no on
on the the um the was it the bedford's
law
ben frankford's law point you made it is
interesting because
well to clarify i'm it's not a point i'm
sure that you referenced that people
there's like people are posting these
viral twitter
people are posting about people are
posting these threads the one thing that
is definitely the case about this
election which is
somewhat unusual is that turnout
nationwide went up
across the board across partisan lines
so we still have millions of votes to
count
ridiculously at this point but even up
until now
something like 12 more total votes were
cast in 2020 compared to 2016
and it they weren't cast in a direction
that's easily
easy to delineate along partisan lines
so if you look at the
map of the country there are some places
that skewed heavily
democratic some places that skewed
heavily republican and
in 2016 the sku was almost universally
toward the republican except in a few
cases
uh like you know northern virginia uh
some affluent suburban areas and you
could like kind of extrapolate what the
reason for that partisan sku was
so it made sense that montgomery council
county pennsylvania and arlington
skewed democratic in 2016 whereas the
other counties
skewed republican but this year it's
harder
to make any of those kinds of inferences
and there are these
regional anomalies that are a little bit
odd
and i'm not positing any conspiracy by
any means i'm just saying that if it's
some of this stuff strikes you as odd
it's because even the people who are
not in conspiracy lamb whatsoever are
finding the mod and don't know exactly
how to interpret
them so like for example one thing that
i wouldn't have expected
is that in uh minnesota which
the trump campaign i think at least
initially thought was possibly
competitive
you see a pretty stark um
pro-democratic sku right but but in iowa
which
parts of which are culturally and
politically very similar
to minnesota you see
the opposite skewed toward the
republican uh toward trump
uh and that's a little odd like i don't
know
exactly how to interpret that and there
are a bunch of other examples like
um if you had told me two weeks ago that
trump would win the second congressional
district in maine by the margin he did
which is like seven points
um i would have found it bizarre that
that would have been the case
and yet he also loses new hampshire by
something like seven or eight points
like because usually
usually there are these inner regional
correlations right at least that was
definitely the case in 2016
the midwest and the great plains swung
hard to trump
right but but this year in the midwest
and the great plains you see these like
patches
of different partisan skus that you know
are going to take a little bit more
examination to understand the phone
people have noticed that in the uh the
the partisan swing
charts where it shows like yeah which
areas
they keep posting photos saying look at
the state lines because
they don't make sense like the border of
ohio and michigan
i think is it was a horrible boarding
machine i'm thinking in indiana um
no it doesn't exist yeah michigan's
north it's like you see michigan is all
going
democrat and then like the state's
bordering it to the south are all going
republican and it's like
well it's like i guess it could happen
with the internet
the fracturing of mentalities you know
you're maybe more like someone across
the country than you are to your
neighbor now
that you're able to connect via the
internet that's one way yeah but in 2016
there was a definitely observable
regional correlation pretty much
everywhere and if what there wasn't a
regional correlation
you could infer that it was due to like
socio-economic status media and
household
income there were like some metrics that
you could use to make these results
explicable whereas in 2020 it's much
less
exploitable explicitly i mean there are
certain things that you can
pretty easily infer from like so for
example the reason why biden
is ahead in georgia is because of this
transformation of the atlanta area and
the suburbs namely the affluent suburbs
and there are other examples that you
can find around the country but others
where it's not
like that correlation doesn't hold um
but you know just to focus on georgia
just because i happen to be there for
like a week
or so prior to the election one thing i
think is worth
underscoring about these results is that
the democratic party's
cultural and power and financial base is
now indisputably in these affluent
suburbs
they're the party of wall street the
managerial elite well i mean the wall
street and wall street was very much
satisfied with this result i mean
the dow went up and so on and so forth
but
because there it's places like cobb
county uh georgia gwinnett county
georgia which are these affluent
growing population centers around metro
areas
the democrats are increasingly going to
govern with their sensibilities in mind
right and if you think that translates
into like economic populism
i think you're dreaming it could there
could be a big factor here in that
uh coven moved people around people who
lived in cities all of a sudden found
themselves back in the suburbs with
their family
and this was always going to be a factor
so when you look at why
there are these patches that we don't
understand it could very easily be that
that earlier in the year covet hit
people probably were like i'm gonna get
out of the city
then when the riots hit people got out
of cities we we knew they were
500 000 people from new york so you got
a bunch of wealthy new york people
moving all across
maybe that explains why maine you know
swung for trump in a certain way that
new hampshire didn't
because people moved very rapidly and it
was the individuals not the exchange of
ideas
you know what i mean just saying yeah
and not relatable and different states
have different regimens in terms of
whether they sent out a universal
mail-in ballot
uh that's true whether you had to apply
for one like in georgia you actually had
to apply for an
absentee ballot whereas like new jersey
where i live
it was it was automatic which i know was
controversial but like a lot of this
stuff really is bizarre like los angeles
county i can't get over
as of yesterday when i checked and it's
probably more now there were 200 more
200 000 more votes for trump in los
angeles county than there were in 2016.
wow and los angeles county is actually
trending republican oh that's
amazing no which is like because the
rich people all leave
and the poor people are like i'm gonna
vote republican uh maybe there's
something to that but like
i mean i would have you would have look
at
not had you i would have not predicted
that one you see zap at a county in
texas
oh yeah i mean hillary clinton hillary
clinton won it two to one
and then trump flipped it hispanic
hispanic uh
uh county and then while some in miami i
think it was what was the 20th or 27th
district blue safe blue congressional
seats turned red
it's also a woman women started crying
on the phone because she lost it's
evidence for why direct democracy is so
dangerous
because of the way people can flip on a
dime and
completely alter if we didn't have a
republic and everyone was just like you
just needed a bunch of people to change
their mind one day
like a populist candidate could just
completely destroy the the governance oh
look at look at like mask wearing
like early on with covid you had all
these republicans being like i'm gonna
wear a mask
and and it was fouchy saying no no and
then it flipped for some reason
like that that's that's that's i'm
agreeing with you in that
you could use a tribal issue to make
people ch 180 their opinions
in in a short time span you know another
thing about this election is that it
doesn't
lend itself to easily uh
reductionist tribal explanations yeah
for the right or the left
i mean i've been examining the georgia
results in in detail because i wrote a
piece that's going to be coming out this
week but
you know i'll just pull up this data
because it's hilarious oh sorry
um so trump would have won this election
if he had just maintained the level of
white support that he had in 2016.
yeah and if
your thesis for
u.s politics is this all-encompassing
you know white supremacy determinantist
belief system that is so prevalent in
the media
then how do you explain that one and one
of the most
stark examples is to me in in in georgia
where you have the county with the
highest proportion of black voters
in that county trump received 38 percent
more total votes than he did
wow in 2016. whereas biden received more
than hillary but just 10 more so the
skew there was for trump
right but then if you look at the
whitest county in georgia these are
rural relatively small counties so you
could see big
shifts year to year but nonetheless in
the whitest county in georgia
biden's vote total increased 34
compared to hillary and trump's
increased
by a lesser percentage of 26. so
what does that tell you that tells you
if you are so mired
in this kind of elite mentality where
everything
is black and white per the dictates of
this
ideology that they're so obsessed with
then you're missing just a huge
amount of the political dynamics in the
country around you and you would think
that if you're in the media
and you're somebody who wants to be as
attuned as possible to those dynamics
then
you would do i don't know everything but
i can't imagine that they're actually
going to do it they're way too tethered
to their ideological pre-explanations
they're they're trying to claim now i'm
seeing all the all the memes from the
from the left that you know aoc was
right
the districts that she helped that were
for medicare for all
actually won and the democrats who
didn't support it went moderate all
ended up losing
and maybe maybe there's an argument
where if i'm going to vote for someone
who's moderate i'll go the safe route
not vote for the guy who wants to
impeach the president not get anything
done
if you vote for a republican maybe
they'll actually do their job maybe
that's the mentality yeah you know maybe
in new jersey jeff andrew he won he won
he just said you know i don't want to
impeach trump i'm going to switch
parties boom boom boom boom
boom and then he's re-elected yep that's
huge
yeah you know it's interesting because
the
the they were the
one of the democratic congressmen who
did not vote to impeach trump there were
only three i think
was in minnesota in one of these you
know more rural districts that had been
like a legacy democratic district that
the republicans rightly thought that
they could win colin peterson
yeah and his not voting for impeachment
didn't matter he still lost anyway
so there there are certain congressional
districts that are going to be subject
to
nationwide trends regardless of whether
like you support medicare for all or you
voted to impeach trump it's almost like
in ineluctable you know and i think you
see that when there's
certain big shifts but then again it's
sort of complicated because you have
these patches of
partisan trends that are kind of like in
conflict with one another that don't
make a ton of sense so it's kind of i
mean this is going to take a lot
of time to quote unpack i think i think
hobart played a big role in it i do
i think i think and the riots moved
people around in ways we don't
understand and a lot of these places had
same-day registration
so you could have literally moved a week
before well not literally because they
probably have some law like you have to
be there at least 27 days or something
some states now they're all going to go
to georgia you hearing this like
they're going to move to georgia they
are so the big thing now apparently is
that georgia has lacks
residency laws and because the runoff
will dictate control of the senate
and if republicans lose control of the
senate it's going to be democrat in
every branch except for the
i should say not the supreme court but
it's going to be house senate and
presidency and they're going to start
passing everything and just steamrolling
through
so now we're hearing was it andrew yang
said i'm moving to georgia
really dude i mean even if the democrats
do gain control of the senate
i wouldn't think i wouldn't overestimate
how simple it is for them to just get
through whatever it is they want to get
through i mean trump
and the republicans had unified control
for the first two years of his tenure
they couldn't get health care uh repeal
obamacare appeal passed
i mean they got a tax reform bill but
but it's it's less it's it's not as
simple as you think and
they're always these kind of like um
anomalous senators within the coalition
who need to be placated i mean trump had
susan collins and lisa murkowski and
stuff
by the way susan collins winning was one
of the most hilarious is it because
certain senators are getting
i keep saying bribed getting uh lobbied
to vote a certain way and if
they're republican or democrat the
lobbyists don't care they're just gonna
lobby
enough people whether well i mean if
you're joe manchin who's the senate
democratic senator from west virginia
clearly you have you're operating under
a wholly different set
of political incentives than if you're a
democratic senator from california right
so i mean
he is within an incentive structure that
is going to put him off course
with what the majority of the caucus
wants and so it's not never going to be
a given that joe manchin is going to
support
anyone give any any particular
legislative initiative i mean joe
manchin voted for um
uh kavanaugh and gorsuch so a democratic
senator from a certain state might be
more conservative than a republican
senator from a certain way but we're
losing that
we're losing that i mean and that used
to always be the case when there was
nothing
surprising or novel about that for most
of us history
but we have seen polarization where it's
almost like the parties act as
parliamentary parties
where they vote in almost complete
unison most of the time
whereas there were there used to be
these regional disparities where you'd
you know it didn't really matter if you
were a democrat or republican if you
were
representing uh in the senate from you
know alabama
and more than alabama just flipped
republican though doesn't it didn't it
it was uh the alabama senator was uh was
democrat
i think uh yes yes doug jones
uh lost that did flip he lost to tommy
tuberville who was like a football coach
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so colin peterson too so colin
peterson was uh
one of the one of the two democrats who
didn't vote for impeachment
or actually i think tulsi abstained did
she she did
she voted president president president
president do you guys voted president on
both of them you guys think there would
be any value to regulating our
government and saying
you you have to have a certain amount of
parties in the government you can't have
more than like x amount of people per
party no because they just form
coalitions they would
yeah and but so well that means
you have lots of parties in different
parliamentary systems like in europe
like
right look at look at belgium they have
to have these wide coalitions and such
yeah
and yeah i think it's arguable whether
these systems are more
efficient but you know one thing i think
probably is valid is ranked choice
voting which is now being adopted
i think
people were actually confident that
susan collins might lose in maine
because the green party votes would go
to
the democratic didn't matter at all
third parties were completely irrelevant
so
i mean these polarization trends that
are evident in the country might
render it so that it's just naturally
not the case that there's a desire for
more than
two parts but ranked choice is legit
right choice sounds pretty good in my
opinion yeah so it's like yeah
but especially in a primary it makes a
lot of sense i actually i i have more
than one
can that you favor you know i actually
uh watched a
video where they did an algorithmic
simulation of various uh voting methods
the method we have is called first past
the post and i think this is archaic
and i think it is held on to by people
who just want to manipulate
one person one vote that's fair and it's
like
there's other ways to determine like
ranked choice makes a lot of sense but
it's also not perfect for those that
aren't familiar ranked choice would be
like
you have a list of candidates and you
say here's my first second third fourth
you you rank them based on what you
think you want that way
if you're like i really want jill stein
i vote for her
but if jill stein loses then your vote
passes down to the next person which
would be you know
joe biden or whatever right and so that
would create a better representation of
who the people actually want
but but this is gonna be surprising
because i didn't realize this
they did a simulation where they showed
the same problem
emerges you can look at many countries
where they have ranked choice voting i
think they mentioned australia could be
wrong and they're like still
two-party dominance because people get
worried
i forgot why it happens but it's a
similar thing where it's like
you run the risk of someone else getting
more
votes because your first choice is not
like
it's still a ranking system where
someone might get more votes if you rank
them at number two or something like
that
and so i forgot how it worked but anyway
the point was they did one called
approval voting
where you literally vote for anybody and
everybody you can vote as many times as
you want
and they said that was actually the best
system so if there's 10 candidates you
can say i vote for all of them and you
can walk away oh
yep interesting alaska actually had a
ranked choice
party run primary this year it's just
like when they were
four or five you know you could choose
you know number one bernie sanders
number two
elizabeth warren whatever um and you
know there's no reason why that couldn't
be replicated across the country
especially in primaries which
tend to be more a function of inter
internal party processes um
you know if there's one election reform
that i would love to be instituted
nationwide because it
best reflects my own beliefs it's that
it's take the option that's on the
ballot to my knowledge only in nevada
which is on the ballot in nevada for any
election you can vote for
uh none of these candidates yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it's just a wholesale
rejection of everything
the whole system i love it and that's my
preferred reform i would love
to vote for them the approval voting
system was interesting because the idea
was if there are say 10 candidates
you can say i vote for this this this
this and this and
everyone else can go away and then
basically it's just whoever gets the
most most win vote
most votes wins and apparently they did
simulation where they found that it
is the most likely system to accurately
represent what people actually
want yeah i think with ranked choice the
problem is your vote's going to end up
being
only going to whoever is the top two of
everything
so if you vote for like a democrat is
number one
and a republican is number two but the
republican doesn't make it into the
final top two
your number two won't be your second
choice it'll defer to your third choice
so you want to put your your republican
as your first choice
i think it was it was something like if
you've got 100 people
and 60 of them vote for someone you like
and you vote for that person but like as
your second choice or something then
it was something like people start
betting against each other
because they're worried about you know
someone bad getting in so they pick
their first choice but then put their
bet as their second choice
and then it creates two-party dominance
with some minor choices here and there
and what's this other one called were
you approval approval where just vote
for as many times as you want so you're
kind of voting for who you don't want
exactly yep and so it ends up with
everyone just you count the votes and
how many
you could vote for one person one time
but you can vote for everybody so i'm
not going to pretend to have all the
answers i'm not saying that's a perfect
system it was just a really interesting
thing where they did a mathematical
equation and then calculated like
you know how many times until they found
accurate representation
and the thing is like people speculate
about the need for
different facets of election reform
every cycle and almost nothing ever
happens of note
at least on a national scale right
sometimes you do have state-based
reforms
as in maine where they did adopt this
ranked choice voting but i remember in
2016 there was
people pledging with you know from the
bottom of their heart that if we do
anything in the next year and a half
it's going to be we're going to abolish
the electoral college it was like oh
okay
that's a terrible idea i think it used
to be wait wait wait wait yeah what are
your thoughts on that
the electoral college yeah um you know
i i i don't even think it's worth having
an argument as to whether it's good or
bad it just
is it's foundational to the country's
founding principles and we've done it
for 200 plus years 250 years so like why
have this recurring endless debate about
whether it should or shouldn't be
there's pretty much
zero chance ever that it will be changed
and if it was going to be changed
it would have been done while all the
momentum was behind changing it in 2016
when you had all these exercised
something liberals saying that oh my god
the this
you know horrible fascist backed by
russia has been
foisted upon us because of the electoral
college if that was the opportunity to
reform it it would have been
that that would have been when it was
done and it wasn't done things can't
just stay the same forever though you
know
that's why i'm like we have an optimism
bias
we think everything is going to just be
the way it is the way we remember
we're used to these elections where it's
always like
the night of at three in the morning
they're like the final polls are in and
barack obama has won
then you know mccain is like you ran a
good campaign barack and i concede
and that's like we just we grew up with
that and that's normal to us and now we
assume nothing could change
it would be too weird and that's an
optimism bias it's just everything's
gonna stay the same it's gonna
the bad stuff can't happen but certainly
it will at some point we can't just
be stuck in this system and if we don't
change it incrementally it tends to
happen all at once which can be very
dangerous
well now you've got the the the
progressive left you've got the
i don't know if you saw that new york
mag story about the new york times yes i
did
the the staff for the new york times
saying we're standing at the barricades
of like historic change or something
which side are you on like like
it feels like there's a dam holding back
a massive wave
of a new what i don't know what you
called it the
neofascism is that sure
did i call it something yeah yeah yeah
the the the the dogma of the
ideological left i forgot you called it
yeah i don't put words in your mouth
yeah i think you know there there i
think there is an
animated segment of the elite
opinion-making class
which is incredibly racist
i didn't say that i did yeah you said it
not me
although maybe i secretly believe it but
i won't have been here um
which is just beyond exercise over these
past four years i think has been
radicalized
definitely i think social media is a
huge factor in that because you
constantly have to be performing
in terms of how committed you are to
various
ideals and the principle of journalism
becomes subordinate
to that not that journalism is ever some
kind of
pure principle that could be aspired to
by everybody
equally under all circumstances but
if you read that new york magazine piece
it was clear that what was animating
most of the people involved at least who
were quoted in
the enterprise of you know furnishing
the new york times
they weren't motivated by principally
journalism it was a right
straightforwardly political objective
which is that we need to
i don't know exactly overthrow over
white says heteronormative patriarchy
yeah we need to defeat trump we need to
totally change up end these systems of
oppression
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time